an I'm in love with you because you're
just like me you're a dog date me an I'm
single Ron you're going to construct the
stage yes ma'am I really think we should
try and involve this talking
dog a will you go out on a date with me
you're the prettiest dog I've ever
seen and remember when we had sex in the
gutter on Rodney Street I'll never
forget it D I'm going to come over there
and you
up
no
hey wait put it in cark no you forgot
sorry wait I thought I put it in park
Park who my name is Annabelle Vander
crank from the Memphis Vander cranks and
I just about lose my head when the sun
falls down on
my mustache is coming up okay I'm sorry
I need my mustache
glued I have hot snakes you guys what's
hot
snakes it's when the diarrhea comes out
like a hot snake
Cy
I get hot snakes in bubble gut stop
talking about hot
snakes I have one suit my brown se's
three
piece what's your name again Elise yton
El
y
sorry elast
sarin do that again
sorry sorry stupid okay don't play if
you can't deal with the consequences
this is on little
man
[Laughter]
oh sorry guys I lost this little pom pom
that was on my golf glove should be on
the floor somewhere could you help me
look for it real quick should be around
here
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there can we do it again just like that
three more
times will you just help me open this
it's it really thank you what I was
saying is that awesome girls like you
who are you know not classically hot
they can go and they can be rewarded for
an
idiot
so
um so I
[Music]
uh Leslie doesn't like to hear her mommy
talk about
sex no one wants to hear that why don't
you tell us about your escap pigs you
little minks what the is wrong with
you every sorry
I saw your head sorry everything sorry
sorry government brand tooth powder and
it doesn't get your teeth clean and it
tastes like
sh and it doesn't get your teeth clean
and it tastes like